well just when you thought it couldn't  get any dumber the my pillow company led  by mike lindell  has countersued dominion voting systems  seemingly in response to the dominion  suit against my pillow for billions of  dollars related to defamation but here  this is especially crazy because the  crux of the my pillow lawsuit  is that dominion a private company  violated  somehow my pillow's first amendment and  14th amendment rights and violated  section 1983.  that's not how any of this works just  because a private company has been  contracted by a government  doesn't mean that that private company  is the government itself whether they're  operating  twitter or operating a company that  helps with voting that's not how this  works that's not how any of this works  so apparently we'll see them in court  for a very short time until this lawsuit  is easily dismissed